Hello
Freak bitches.
It does change.
I mean hate to to say Louis C take game Gamey,
crazy place once it came to having a kid,
which is very odd.
What'd he said?
Ah,
let it change you and I don't know Louis very well.
She just say this too because people,
somebody,
somebody is giving me a hard time about not commenting on it.
And then Mike,
my thought was like,
first of all,
I want to gather my thoughts.
Absolutely.
And second of all,
I don't know him that well.
I don't even have his phone number.
I've never had a phone call conversations with him.
I bet we've exchanged emails maybe three times ever.
And he and I have run into each other at clubs and said,
hi,
we've never gone out and hung out together.
I'm not good friends with them.
Yeah.
So when all this was going down,
it's not like I had information,
like if Joey Diaz did something fucked up and people wanted me to comment,
first of all,
I would never say anything bad no matter what Joey Diaz did.
Sorry.
That's just the way it is.
If there's just no way around.
Yeah.
If you knew he raped someone,
this is horrible.
I see.
So sorry that he did that,
but when,
you know,
I mean I would never,
I would never throw him under the bus.
You know what I'm saying?
It's like there's bus throwing and then there's bus throwing,
there's a comment after sort of condemning,
condemning it.
And then there's of course like there was a guy who was in that movie baby
driver,
um,
and he asks us basic,
no,
it was like an eighth lead or something.
And he went on some show and just went off about Kevin.
And so everyone's like,
it was like,
it looked like a way to get attention.
Like,
yeah,
when I was on set,
he didn't seem that cool and it was so much in retrospect.
Oh,
but he's not the guy that's on the walking dead,
the punisher guy.
I don't know.
Isn't that him?
I just saw that.
Yeah.
I think it's that guy who's pretty successful.
He's,
he's the new punisher and that net,
it just seemed very like bandwagon jumping when the Louis C K thing happened.
I can speak from a perspective of a woman who's seen this kind of stuff.
I don't know.
I brought him up twice at the store.
That's my knowledge of him.
Right.
But you get these emails from like the New York Times or like,
Hey,
if you have anything you want to say or if you know any other things,
I'm like,
I don't,
and I don't want to attach myself.
I don't want to be like,
I didn't want to be part of that story just for the sake of it.
Right,
right.
Cause then you look like a fame whore.
Well that's also the problem.
Like you get caught up in something where you,
you become inexorably connected to this awful event and you didn't do anything.
Sure.
Yeah.
So Joey didn't do anything.
It was just,
it's like an,
and not Joey Joey,
but oddly enough is,
it's crazy as Joey is,
he's a very gentle person.
He's a giant,
he's Puerto Rican,
he's Cuban.
Sorry.
Giant Cuban teddy bear.
He is right because he seems so tough and he loves saying Cock sucker.
But he is just,
he's like,
he's just so kind.
And he's got these eyes like a whale,
like they're just ancient and big,
like the Hamill eyelashes.
He's got these like lovely I and you and he smiles at you like a toddler.
I love him.
He's the best.
I exchange emails him maybe once every three or four years we've texted each
other maybe 10 times ever.
All only phone calls,
calls me every couple of days.
What's up dog soccer?
What are you doing brother?
What's going on?
It's,
he wants to talk to you.
Yeah.
Joey wants to talk to you.
If I have ever text him is because I have to say send an address to him and now
he's got to like put it in his navigation system.
That's it.
He,
he calls you.
He lovely.
Yeah.
He's,
he's a beautiful person.
Yeah,
it's,
and,
and he's,
you know,
he,
he and I were talking about this whole Louis C k thing is,
he was like,
you know,
he goes,
you know what's fucking crazy?
He was like,
I held somebody at gunpoint.
He goes,
he goes,
it goes full armed fucking kidnapping.
And everybody's like,
hey,
you were crazy.
But he goes like,
this is the kind of thing crazy.
This is the kind of thing that sticks because he did it to one of us,
right?
Like if you in our world like we are all the same.
We are all the same thing.
I mean there's gonna be some weird pettiness and bullshit and there's going to
be some prejudices and it's going to be some individuals that are out
supportive.
But overall amongst the good eggs,
the ones that you and I associate with,
we are all,
we all consider each other the same thing.
Could we,
are,
we understand each other's hearts and we know how hard it is and what it's like.
And we all know that it's us.
Even though the audiences are friends,
it's US versus them.
It's the club versus you know,
you're trying to do a job and we know exactly what this very weird job entails
and we know the way the other person thinks like we have fucked up thoughts.
Yes.
And it's okay to admit these thoughts to each other and it's a very special bond
and you can't just be like,
I'm a comic.
I get it,
like you have to kind of earn it and there's a respect there.
And so it's,
what he did is deplorable and it was with other comics.
And I feel bad because I feel bad because everybody gets so angry at women.
They're like,
why now?
And I'm like,
cause there's safety in numbers and no one would listen before.
[inaudible].